من جهته نشر جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي صورا
قال انها لغارات استهدفت منطقه بلده مركبه
جنوب لبنان وافاد المتحدث باسم الجيش
الاسرائيلي باستهداف الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه مباني عسكريه وموقع استطلاع
ومواقع اطلاق قذائف لحزب الله في البلده
كما هاجم عده مناطق في جنوب لبنان
بالدبابات والطائرات دون ذكر تفاصيل هذه
الغارات هذا وقد قال وزير الدفاع الاسرائ
وافلان انه حتى لو اوقف حزب الله عملياته
فلن نتوقف او تتوقف اسرائيل حتى تغيير
الوضع الامني على الحدود الشماليه واضاف
جلان خلال اجتماعه بوزير الدفاع الفرنسي
سيباستيان لي كورنو ان الحرب مع حزب الله
ستكون قاسيه على اسرائيل ومدمره لحزب الله
ولبنان على حد
تعبيره
معنا الان من الجليل الاعلى مراسله
الجزيره جيفارا البديري معنا من ابل السقي
جنوبي لبنان مراس الجزيره ايهاب العقدي
جفار ضعين في اخر مستجدات هذا الوضع
الميداني وكذلك تصريحات وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي فيما يتعلق باستمرار هذا
الهجوم او الحرب على الحدود الشماليه حتى
وان توقف حزب
الله بدايه على الصعيد الميداني ايمان بعد
تكتم ل 24 ساعه اصدر المتحدث العسكري
الاسرائيلي بيان قال فيه انه تم استهداف
بلده مارون الراس حيث تم استهداف مبنى ب
عده صواريخ من طائرات حربيه اسرائيليه
وانه تم رصد عدد من عناصر حزب الله في
داخل هذا المبنى ولكن ما حدث انه بعد
الهجوم
تم حدوث انفجارات وصفها بالثانويه وقال
انها واضح نتيجه
اي وجود كثير من المتفجرات والاسلحه في
داخل هذا المبنى ولكن في ذات الوقت هو
يؤكد انه تعرض للقصف من قبل حزب الله في
عده مواقع على الاقل اربع مواقع من وكذلك
هو ايضا يقول انه تم قصف ايضا اربع مواقع
ثلاثه منها للمراقبه وواحد ل
مجمع عسكري في مروحين وشحن والطيبه وطير
حرفه في الجنوب اللبناني صافرات الانذار
لم تدوي منذ منتصف الليله الماضيه حتى هذه
اللحظه ولكن ما يحدث سياسيا هو الاهم كما
ذكرتي ايمان وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي خلال
لقاء جمعه اليوم بوزير الدفاع الفرنسي قال
بان حزب الله ان توقف عن اطلاق القذائف
والصواريخ فذلك لا يعني ان اسرائيل ستتوقف
عن مهاجمه مواقع الحزب في داخل لبنان حتى
تامين عوده كل السكان النازحين بامان الى
البلدات الحدوديه حسب وصف جلنت والاهم انه
قال ان الحرب على لبنان ستكون صعبه على
اسرائيل ولكن في ذات الوقت هي ستكون مدمره
على لبنان وحزب الله شيء اخير وهو مهم ان
اجتماع مجلس الكابينت الاسرائيلي سيم قد
يوم غد في منطقه مرج ابن عامر اي القريبه
على الجليل وسكان البلدات الشماليه دعيو
الى حضور هذا الاجتماع لكنهم يرفضون
وقالوا اذا الحكومه خائفه من الوصول الى
الشريط الحدودي والى الجليل فنحن لا نريد
هذه الحكومه ويبقى الشريط الحدودي هو حز
شكرا انتقل اليك ايهاب العقدي من ابل
السقي في جنوبي لبنان استهداف مبان عسكريه
ومواقع استطلاع وايضا مواقع اطلاق قذائف
لحزب الله كيف بدا الوضع الميداني وهل من
ردود فعل على هذه التصريحات الاسرائيليه
فيما يتعلق بحرب قاسيه ومدمره كما قال
وزير
الدفاع بالنسبه للبنان الرسمي وايضا لحزب
الله ما يقوم به في جنوب لبنان هو اسناد
للشعب الفلسطيني وللمقاومة
في غزه عندما تنتهي الحرب في غزه وتتوقف
عندها يتوقف العمل العسكري في جنوب لبنان
هذا هو الموقف العام بالنسبه للحكومه
وبالنسبه لحزب الله طوال فتره انطلاق ال
منذ انطلاق العمليات العسكريه في السابع
من اكتوبر والثامن من اكتوبر في لبنان هو
الموقف المتوازن بين الدوله وحزب الله حول
ما يجري حزب الله لم يتوقف عن هذه
العمليات اطلاقا وهو م ستمر فيها يعتقد
ومعه ايضا السلطات والوزراء ونواب كسر في
الجانب اللبناني بان لدى اسرائيل ازمه
اجتماعيه ناتجه عن هذه المعارك الدائره في
بين جنوب لبنان وشمال اسرائيل اي بين حزب
الله والجيش الاسرائيلي وان هناك ضغوطا
ترتب على الحكومه وعلى المستوى السياسي
تقديم اداء وتصريحات تخفف من وطاه ما يجري
في شمال اسرائيل حزب الله يواصل هذه
العمليات والطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه
كذلك تواصل قصفها مناطق مختلفه من جنوب
لبنان وتلك القريبه من الحدود اخر هذه
الاستهدافات كان في بلده خربه سلم قبل بعض
الوقت استهدفت منزلا ايضا استهدفت الغارات
خمس مناطق اخرى وفي جنوب لبنان كل هذه
الغارات لم تؤدي الا الى تدمير منزل في
بلده الطيبه اعلن بعده حزب الله عن
استشهاد احد
مقاتليه لم يشر حزب الله الى اي نعي يتعلق
بال المواقع التي كانت اعلنها الجيش
الاسرائيلي وتحديدا تلك التي وقعت في
مارون الراس ومناطق اخرى اذ ان كل الهجمات
بالطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه لم تؤدي
خلال الساعات ال8 الماضيه الا الى اصابه
الا الى نعي شخص واحد من حزب الله
المدفعيه الاسرائيليه كانت اليوم ايضا
شاركت باطلاق قذائف حارقه على مناطق
مختلفه في جنوب لبنان نم اخرها كان في
كفركلا وبعض القرى القريبه منها شكرا لك
ايهاب العقدي كنت معنا من جنوب لبنان